uh why don't Flames have shadows like I
mean hello it's kind of freaky but it
has everything to do with what a
hydrocarbon flame is when you look at a
candle flame the part you can see is not
a gas and it's not a plasma believe it
or not the part you can see is a solid a
flame is a chemical salad full of wax
and oxygen molecules that are burning
carbon dioxide and water vapor that are
products of the combustion as well as
hot air and unburnt solid fuel particles
that are so hot they're glowing
incandescently that's where the light
comes from but all of this stuff is not
very crowded in fact a flame is about
only a quarter as dense as the
surrounding air so light can pass right
on through whatever Shadow is created
can be easily filled in by the glow of
the flame itself what the flame mainly
does to light can be revealed by using a
light that is brighter than the flame
light travels at different speeds
through media that have different
densities so passing from the hot flame
to the cooler air we get ghostly
distortions of intensity that are the
only evidence that anything's there